أدوليا
، شكرًا جزيلاً لك على استضافتي في برنامجك ،
إنه لمن دواعي سروري المطلق أن أعني
أنه سؤال جيد لماذا نغير
اسمنا إلى Red Sea Global أعني بشكل
أساسي أنه يعكس حقًا
تطور الشركة التي بدأناها
كتطوير البحر الأحمر  عندما
كنا نطور مشروعًا واحدًا لوجهة واحدة ،
لكن كان لدي طموح
في البداية في عام 2018 لإنشاء
بطل إقليمي للمملكة العربية السعودية ،
شركة يمكنها القيام بمشاريع في جميع
أنحاء المملكة ولكن أيضًا ما
وراءها واليوم نعلن عن التغيير  من
اسمنا لشركة Red Sea Global لتعكس
هذا الطموح ، لدينا الآن عشرات
المشاريع في أعلى وأسفل الساحل الغربي
للمملكة العربية السعودية ، لذا فمن المناسب
أن نجري هذا التغيير ،
كما أننا نطمح أيضًا لقيادة
العالم ليكون أفضل من أجله.  لكل من
الناس وللكوكب وأعتقد أنه
اسم مناسب لشركة البحر الأحمر ،
حسنًا بالتأكيد هذا هو
الطموح النهائي أعتقد أن لدينا لوحة
كاملة للغاية في  لقد لحظة كما قلت ، لدينا
عشرات المشاريع بما في ذلك البحر الأحمر
وأمالا ، وكلاهما من مشاريع جيجا
ولدي مشاريع أخرى
ربما تكون كبيرة إن لم تكن أكبر ولكننا
نبني القدرات التي لدينا
الطموح الذي نمول من خلاله  صندوق الاستثمار العام ،
لذلك لا يوجد
ما يعيقنا عن البحث عن
الفرص على الصعيدين الإقليمي وفي
جميع أنحاء العالم ،
ومن الواضح أن خبرتنا الآن
تركز على السياحة ، لكن
القدرات التي نبنيها داخل شركة
البحر الأحمر العالمية لا حدود
لها حقًا  أنواع المشاريع التي قد
نبنيها سنبني تجاريًا وسنقوم
ببناء متاجر التجزئة وبالطبع ستضعنا تجربة المنتجع لدينا
في حالة
جيدة جدًا وليس مختلفًا ، إنه تطور كما
قلت إنك تعلم أن نفس المهارات
مطلوبة  سواء كنت تقوم ببناء
منتجعات أو ما إذا كنت تقوم ببناء
مباني المكاتب أو ما إذا كنت تقوم
ببناء مبنى سكني في الواقع فإننا نقوم
بالفعل ببناء كل هذه
الأجزاء المكونة لأن  تعد
المشاريع السياحية حقًا متعددة الأبعاد حيث
قلت إنها تشمل الوحدات السكنية
وتشمل البيع بالتجزئة وبالطبع
تشمل الفنادق ، لذا تظل المهارات
كما هي وستكون
قابلة للتكيف بسهولة مع أنواع أخرى من
فئات الأصول.  إعادة بناء
وجهات ذات مستوى عالمي
تنافس أفضل المنتجعات
في أي مكان في العالم ، لكننا في الواقع
نتقدم خطوة أبعد من ذلك لأنني أعتقد
أن العالم يمر بأزمة
لمجموعة متنوعة من الأسباب ولكن خاصة
عندما يتعلق الأمر  المناخ والبيئة
والنهج الذي اتخذناه في البحر الأحمر
هو التركيز حقًا على
التنمية المتجددة وهذا يعني أن
نحاول بالفعل جعل المكان أفضل وبالتالي
أسلوب الحياة وجودة
البيئة التي نحاول خلقها
هو حقًا تضمين أنفسنا في الطبيعة
ومن ثم منح الأشخاص تجربة فريدة
لا تجدها حقًا في
أي مكان آخر في العالم لأننا
نبني تطورات
تتماشى مع  البيئة بدلاً من
الإضرار بالبيئة أو استغلالها ،
وهو ما حدث حتى الآن ، لذا
أعتقد أن أحد
الفروق الرئيسية التي سيحققها كل من البحر الأحمر
وأمالا حتى يسعد زوارنا
وضيوفنا تمامًا ولكننا  سيكون
لها تأثير ضئيل على بيئتنا المحلية ،
انظر إلى جوهر
الحمض النووي الخاص بنا تمامًا هو التزامنا بالتنمية المتجددة
التزامنا بجعل
الكوكب أفضل لرعاية الأشخاص
سواء موظفينا أو ضيوفنا
أو الأشخاص أيضًا  في مجتمعاتنا المحلية
، أعتقد أن هذا جزء كبير جدًا مما
يمثله البحر الأحمر ويظل
ركيزة أساسية في المنظمة للمضي قدمًا.
سيتم افتتاح أولها في
ربيع العام المقبل ، لذا سنفتتح
ثلاثة منتجعات العام المقبل ، ثم
سيتم افتتاح 13 منتجعًا آخر في عام 2024 ، لكن أمالا
ليست بعيدة عننا.  ثمانية منتجعات
قيد الإنشاء هناك
ستفتتح وترحب بأول ضيوفنا في نهاية
عام 2024. لقد جمعنا 14 مليار ريال من
خلال تمويل أخضر ، وهو الأكبر من
نوعه على الإطلاق بالريال السعودي المقوم بالريال السعودي
المعتمد من قبل HSBC لذلك تم اعتماده
كتمويل أخضر حقيقي وهو
تمييز مهم للغاية لأنه
يعني أن الأموال يتم استخدامها
لتحقيق الاستدامة البيئية
وهو ما يدور حوله البحر الأحمر في نهاية المطاف
ولكن لدينا أيضًا شراكة واسعة النطاق
بين القطاعين العام والخاص مع شركة
aquapower التي تعمل على تطوير
البنية التحتية للطاقة المتجددة
ولدينا RFP في السوق للقيام
بالمثل في Amala ، وقعنا أول
شراكة مشروع مشترك مع
مجموعة عائلية كبيرة لتطوير أحد منتجعاتنا ، لذا
نحاول حقًا جعل
القطاع الخاص جزءًا من الرحلة
أن البحر الأحمر يقع على أن المملكة
ماضية في تنويع الاقتصاد والابتعاد عن
الاعتماد البحت على الفوائد النفطية.
مثل البحر الأحمر ، نحن ممولون بالكامل
على نموذج ، فإن المشروع يمضي
قدمًا في PACE كما قلت أن لدينا
ثمانية منتجعات قيد الإنشاء ،
أطلقنا تصميمات
لنادي اليخوت الجميل لدينا معهد الحياة البحرية الذي
تعرفه كبير جدًا-  تسلق مارينا
لاستقبال اليخوت من جميع أنحاء العالم
وخاصة من البحر الأبيض المتوسط
وسيكمل هذا المشروع المرحلة الأولى
بحلول نهاية عام 2024 ولكننا
نخطط بالفعل للمراحل
اللاحقة لمواصلة البناء على الزخم
الذي أنشأناه من أجل  التاريخ قريب جدا